12 weeks for 12 pounds subscribe to the
spectator for this excellent deal
and get a 20 pound amazon voucher at www
dot spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
welcome to holy smoke the spectator's
religion podcast
i'm damian thompson
[Music]
my guest today is a member of a family
that has at various times
ruled austria hungary spain portugal
the netherlands burgundy large parts of
italy
croatia bosnia southern poland and
mexico you will guess from that that his
surname can only be
habsburg and it is edward hafsberg
is hungary's ambassador to the holy see
and i know him as do many people through
twitter
edward whose family title is archduke
edward of austria is also an
unofficial online ambassador for his
catholic
faith his twitter feed is more uplifting
and funny than that of any bishop i can
think of
he writes as he says to show the world
that catholics are not
sad prudish and world fleeing weirdos
well at the moment i think the jury is
out on that particular question but he
certainly proved that he isn't
i'm just looking at his tweets now and i
see that he's got a
thread up on the growing beard of franz
joseph
that's his great great grandfather the
emperor franz joseph
which catalogues in paintings how
the emperor's whiskers gradually joined
forces with his moustache to culminate
in says there would
a final stage in which france joseph
could stare down jason robards in once
upon a time in the west
and there are pictures of the two men to
prove the point
the cinematic reference is typical
though sadly
the zombie movie that edward wrote never
went into production
he is however the author of two short
books on james bond and
harry potter other running themes are as
you might expect
the spectacular success of the hungarian
government's family policy
and his profound devotion to the blessed
virgin mary
on the feast of the assumption he
tweeted out honor our lady by going to
mass and
what do you say praying a rosary it's
not that hard
two smilies you just need ten fingers
anyway it's no surprise that he has
twenty seven thousand followers
which i notice is a thousand more me i'm
gonna have to do something about that
we've only met a couple of times but
he's definitely somebody i count as a
friend
not least because as you may know my
sister carmel who's
a brilliant occasional co-presenter of
this podcast
has cancer and edward although he's
never met her has prayed for her every
single day for the last 18 months
i caught up with him earlier the sound
quality isn't great it sounds a little
bit as if it was recorded in some
cavernous habsburg palace but he's never
lived him mon
i'm slightly kicking myself because it
was only after i spoke to edward that i
looked at a fascinating
wikipedia article on the origins of the
famous
habsburg jaw which got an awful lot to
do with
what's diplomatically turned cousin into
marriage
but let me assure you he's a very
handsome trap and doesn't have one
i mean he has a draw but not a habsburg
jewel anyway i began by raising a rather
trivial point which is
i was brought up to call the family the
hapsburgs with a p
but i gather that this is a terrible
solacism well that's a long discussion i
had it on twitter
all over i've become very tolerant of
the p in habsburg because i've been told
after being angry about it for one or
two years
that it is long time practice in the
english language to spell it that way
in fact very long in fact since the 16th
century more or less
and therefore it's okay in the english
speaking world to spell habsburg with a
p
on the continent of course we spell it
with a b and yes
damian i am one of that family and to be
precise of the hungarian branch of the
habsburgs
which explains of course why i'm an
ambassador for hungary but if you really
want to know exactly where i fit into
the family tree we can have a nice
20-minute conversation about
well i think it would take more 20
minutes actually i mean just your own
immediate family tree has
hasbergs on both sides but the actual
family tree of the heblog family it's it
just does your head in
i mean you ruled austria from the 13th
century to
the 20th century and were holy roman
emperors for much of that time
but when you lost that title became
emperors of austria
and the first emperor austria in 1804
styled himself not just emperor of
austria but king of jerusalem
hungary bohemia dalmatia croatia
slavonia galicia and lodameria archduke
of austria duke of lorraine salzburg
wurzburg franconia styria corinthia and
carniola
grand duke of krakow grand prince of
transylvania margrave of moravia duke of
sandomere
maservio lublin upper and lower silesia
auschwitz and zato teshin and fueller
prince of pekka's garden and
mergentime prince the count of habsburg
gorizia and gradicia under the
tyrol and margrave margrave love that
of upper and lower lusatia and estria
but that's not the whole of the story by
any means because
and earlier branch of the hasbergs had
ruled
spain and portugal and the spanish
netherlands
and the austrians later very unhappily
got entangled in mexico when an archduke
of austria
accepted the title of the emperor of
mexico and was executed there in 1867
and talking of executions uh habsburg
archduchess was executed
in france in 1793 by which time
she had in fact become the french queen
mary antoinette
that's extremely well known of course
less well-known perhaps
is that the hasberg supplied a king of
england
in name anyway because when philip of
spain
famously married queen mary he was given
the title king of england though
it wasn't monarch but that didn't work
out either anyway obviously none of this
is news to you edward but i'm just
pointing it out to illustrate the fact
that
the habsburgs have been everywhere and
really if you
know the history of your family that
that would be almost enough to get you a
history degree
at least in the days before history was
farmed out to black lives matter
but it did all come to an end in 1918
or perhaps you could say in sarajevo in
1914 when
the assassination of a habsburg
triggered the first world war but the
family is
still around and there are still several
branches and i'm still a bit
confused so if you could just help me
with that
there is basically four one of them is
what i would call the vienna branch
one of them is the tuscany branch that
descended from the
dukes of tuscany habsburg then there is
um the teschen branch which are the
descendants of
archduke carl the man who beat napoleon
in
the first land battle that napoleon lost
and the youngest branch is the hungarian
branch
and so you have four branches of the
habsburgs and
we are all together about three to four
hundred people all over the world
we all know each other we get along with
each other
and are all in the whatsapp group a
whatsapp group for habsburgs that's
that's quite surreal yes most people
think that we spend our time
opening and closing dusty books about
family history
but we actually have arrived in 21st
century and we have a whatsapp group
and some local habsburg family groups
have their own whatsapp group so
we are very much in modern times and
what do you talk about
we debate history we have one or two
really good
family historians we usually share
articles
that came out about the family so family
members all over the world
know what is being talked about in
connection with our family
and are able to answer to that too which
whenever you know a claim is put out
somewhere on
in the world in an article on the
internet and we want to know well
is that true is the first world war our
fault and all of that
and then births deaths pictures of
babies pictures of cute animals
and do you find yourself discussing the
problem of bogus
habsburgs because i know for some reason
this is an area that's always fascinated
me it's quite funny
the phenomenon of bogus european
aristocrats
it can be so difficult to tell whether
somebody's real or not because
titles were granted all over the place
by all sorts of different people
and there are lots of grey areas whereas
whatever you think of the british
aristocracy there really are no grey
areas at all because there's only one
fountain of honor who's the monarch and
so you can instantly discover whether
somebody's entitled to a title or not
i can think of just one exception
recently which was when
some horrendous chancer managed to
acquire
a knighthood from the queen but it was
united in a former colony
in other words a foreign country of
which the queen's head of state and
actually
she didn't know that it had been granted
and
in the end buckingham palace and the
foreign office
and the college of arms had to intervene
to stop him using it and then he was
stripped of it anyway
but i would have thought that you know
one of the things you might do on this
habsburg whatsapp group is to sort out
the real thing from
imposters there are real hubs books
there are impostors and then there are
people where the situation is
complicated and um
as there are were a few members in the
last 100 years of sort of
semi disappeared or sort of took
themselves out of circulation by
disappearing into some country
it is absolutely possible that offspring
of those turns up
at some point sometimes that happens but
we really
have covered more or less who belongs to
the family then in our family there are
no different title every single habsburg
follow the old title system is an
archduke or an arch duchess of course if
you're in austria you're not allowed to
use that because there are no titles in
austria but just to say
we all the same this is a title we nasty
people say invented several hundred
years ago each other
a fancy title so it's a title that only
exists in our family and don't
overestimate
the glamour that you experience as a
habsburg we're not among the sick
families of europe
really well um if perhaps for example
then
who are the chic families of europe i
won't answer here i'm a diplomat
damien you can't ask me that well fair
enough and as you say you are a diplomat
you're hungary's ambassador to the holy
see and hungary makes sense because
you come from the hungarian branch of
the family and not so long ago members
of your family spoke hungarian as a
first language but it's not a job you
expected to be doing is it that's a very
unusual story because
if you would have asked me two days
before i was asked whether i could
imagine to become ambassador
i would have told you no way i was a
scriptwriter
i was a press officer for a bishop i
worked for television i made a
television series
i have actually written an outline for a
zombie movie
so a zombie movie well yes i wanted to
make a beautiful two-part zombie movie
set in austria but then in the end it
didn't work out so you see i'm not your
typical
ambassador and i'm sorry you're gonna
have to tell me more about this zombie
movie i'm fascinated
oh no oh that was lovely it was supposed
to to depart with a group of young
people in vienna with a zombie outbreak
and they would have to flee to the south
of austria then into the mountains
and survive it was something like that
you know classical stuff
but of course it never took off but i
was a scriptwriter
for a few years i wrote two novels i
wrote several books so
you know my idea of diplomat was
standing around at cocktails with a
glass in your hand
smiling weakly and not being allowed to
say anything
not to cause any any crisis diplomatic
crisis
that was my idea of a diplomat so it was
the furthest possible away from what i
could imagine ever being in my life
and then of course i was asked and i've
discovered that
it's fantastic it's absolutely fantastic
to be a diplomat and i never enjoyed
any job that much as i have enjoyed
being a diplomat in the last years
and it was definitely the right posting
for you wasn't it because
well you are very catholic catholic
faith was something that
came absolutely normally to me through
all our childhood
as you probably know my brother is a
priest and
we were yes absolutely dripping in
catholicism from our childhood
but in a normal way not in an oppressive
way or in a weird way
so when the hungarian government asked
me whether i wanted to be ambassador
to the holy see and you realize they had
thought about it
and i told them look my hungarian is not
really good and they told me well you
learn it but the most important thing is
you speak italian and
you have worked for the church and
they're right i worked five years for a
bishop
so i can speak church so to speak i know
catholic faith i've been interested in
catholic topics in my life i wrote my
thesis in philosophy
about domestic philosophy and the crisis
of thomism
around the second vatican council so
i think you know church papacy
catholic faith was always on my radar
actually
it's in my veins so you can imagine that
being ambassador here
right now is like a child being locked
in overnight in a chocolate factory
well i think it's that very upbeat
attitude towards being a catholic
in very difficult times for the church
that draws people to your twitter feed
and also
your very amusing take on being a
hasberg and
all the centuries of history that come
attached with it
and those two areas come together
when you talk about or when you're asked
about one particular person
an ancestor of yours who died as
recently as 1922
who's been declared blessed by the
church
and that is none other than the last
austro-hungarian emperor
the emperor khan who was only 34 when he
died
in exile in maduro because of course the
austro-hungarian empire and
indeed habsburg rule all seven
eight centuries of it had come to an end
in 1918. and
no one could claim that emperor carl was
one of the great habsburg emperors
because in fact
he was only emperor of austria and king
of hungary for
less than two years his ancient great
uncle franz joseph
died in 1916 and because his heir franz
ferdinand had been assassinated in
sarajevo
young carl found himself catapulted into
this
lofty position and he tried to end the
first world war
and failed obviously and when it ended
he was deposed
he tried to regain the throne of hungary
that failed
there was a miserable exile in madeira
with his wife
and prosita who didn't die until 1989.
he caught pneumonia and it was all over
also it seemed but in 2004 pope john
paul ii declared him
blessed carl of austria recognizing not
only his
personal saintliness but his heroic
attempts to end that terrible war
and edward i know that you have a great
devotion to him
and so do many members of your family
well i would say what makes you saint
you're a saint if you live your vocation
in an extraordinary way you live your
work in an extraordinary way
you live your family life in an
extraordinary way and your personal
relationship with god in an
extraordinary way
and um parenthesis whatsapp group i made
a
little poll on our habsburg whatsapp
group about two years ago
and i said which are your favorite
habsburgs so i asked all of them also
the younger ones the yellow ones
everybody sort of chipped in
and the interesting result is that you
wouldn't think the ones that most people
would say like
charles v or empress maria teresia
no blessed emperor carl was first spot
with a long distance the others
so apparently many of our young family
members
seem really to take him as an example
and
he wasn't spectacular externally
he didn't look imposing he wasn't such a
rock externally like francis joseph was
he looked he smiled a lot he has his
little mustache
you know he didn't seem imposing but
when you enter
the world of thought of prayer personal
piety of love to his wife of incredible
dedication to his
wife his children his empire his peoples
all of this then you meet a giant and
you meet a giant
and um many of our family members feel
that
you know when you're married and you
have children you can look to carl
the way he lived his marriage the way he
loved his wife the way he was there for
his children
the way he taught them faith together
with his wife
when you're a catholic you can look at
the way that he
lived his life for the catholic for
instance he went to mars every day
every single day the only days he
couldn't go was when he was
on the transport ship to madeira for a
few days and it was a nightmare because
he and his wife both
were used to going to holy mouse every
day and they couldn't for a few days and
it was very tough on them
and then you see how from the first day
that he became emperor
he did everything to end the war
at the point where of course it was
already catastrophically far gone
he did so because the pope encouraged
him to do so
and he reached out to end the war and
he did it even behind the back of the
german generals and his own
government in order to get an end to
this war
when he was in madeira and was dying
knew he was dying
not only he called in his son to witness
how an emperor dies
otto otto told me that he remembered
exactly
but he also offered all his sufferings
and he had a really
prolonged and suffering death for his
people and for the countries
so even when he was totally weak and
unable to fulfill
his daily duties as an emperor even from
his deathbed
he tried to do something for the
austro-hungarian empire and for the
people that lived there
so i think that's quite exemplary so i
think he's an example
on every level and we love him in the
family but sustaining that intensity of
religious practice
as a time when there's been a tremendous
fragmentation of ideas about the
supernatural and
a general folding off of adherence to
organize religion generally
that seems an impossible ideal
particularly
in an era of digital technology
it's the 100 million dollar question
isn't it uh it's
it has become extremely difficult to
lead a life centered
around your faith um i think you you
pointed out one of them
the key factors in my opinion is
internet and mobile you are distracted
from the from switching on your phone
while you're even
half awake in the morning to switching
it off
last thing before you after you switched
off the light in your room
i'm overdoing it but that's what you do
so you're entertained
20 hours out of 24 entertained
all the time and i think our psyche
hasn't been
built for that kind of constant
entertainment
just 20 years or 30 years ago there was
no way to entertain yourself with videos
while walking from a to b
you simply had to cope with with with
having to look around and think or talk
to somebody or
reading a book and then being run over
by by a car at the next
red light but um so we are constantly
distracted
and entertained to death and finding
spaces
to center your life on on the principles
of our faith
in these circumstances is very difficult
it helps to have a wife and children it
helps to have
children who take away your phone and
say no daddy no
you are now with us switch that thing
off until of course they have their own
phone so they won't even notice you have
yours on because they're on theirs
but um this is a real problem and i
think it's very unhealthy
for humankind and it won't go away and
it will get even more entertaining over
the next years
one very helpful thing is to pray
without your mobile on
my my family me we have a fixed date in
the afternoon we always pray a rosary
together and the mobiles are switched
off that's very helpful
thank god in summer friends give us a
place where we can stay
we don't have internet reception there
we don't have telephone there
so we are forced to make do with doing
nothing reading
talking or playing that's very useful so
taking times out from this incredible
being amused to death it's very
important
going to mars receiving your sacraments
going to confession
all of this can help to center your life
but i i repeat it has become
far more difficult than even 15 years
ago
and everybody has to see themselves how
they do it
well i have to say i never found it very
easy even in
my definitely pre-digital childhood
when there was absolutely no danger of
us amusing ourselves to death
as you put it though we did quite enjoy
the
two ronnies on a saturday night
obviously our two families didn't have
that much in common
i mean my father's imperial rit didn't
run any further than the front garden of
number 23 woody wood road but it was a
very very observant catholic childhood
like yours mass every sunday
sometimes on a friday as well and god
knows how i
ended up writing about religion for a
living because i i didn't enjoy
the church going all the praying and
there was
only one attempt at a family rosary and
it was a disaster we knelt awkwardly
in front of the sofas they staring at
each other
and god it makes my flesh creep to think
about it actually
the verdict afterwards delivered by my
father was that
one family member had spoiled it for
everybody else
and from what i can remember i'm sure i
did by yawning and
sighing theatrically every time a new
decade of the rosary started
but actually i think my father who was
really the quintessence of
english reserved might have been a bit
embarrassed even if i hadn't been
misbehaving because you'll remember this
was
the 1970s and the rosary was part of the
sort of ancient
popular heritage of devotional practices
that weren't exactly swept away by the
second vatican council
in the way that the trident time mass
was until pobendi restored it
but there was a lot of dismantling going
on and it was dismantling
by the middle classes it was a sort of
dismantling of the devotions that
meant so much to my grandparents and
which is
um stephen bullivant in his brilliant
book mass exodus shows
actually had a very destructive effect
on the fabric of catholic life
but by the time i was a teenager and my
grandparents were either
dead or very old you were probably most
likely to encounter the rosary as a
communal
activity if you stumbled across the
legion of mary saying it together in
church on a saturday morning
and i did stumble across it once and i
hope i'm not being rude when i say that
really it was quite a noise it was done
very fast
in very pronounced irish accents heard
mary for the grace of lords with the
blessed moon
holy mother it seems to get faster and
faster we seem to
have a you know competitive aspect to it
but
actually traditional religion very often
is noisy i mean
if you hear the psalms sung in gaelic on
the isle of lewis
it's quite a racket i mean likewise
shape notes singing in
america and hasidic synagogues are
notoriously far far noisier than
reformed ones but in england at least i
think it did rub up against this
famous english embarrassment which i
think was more pronounced after the
second vatican council
and in god knows how many parishes are
these
modernizing busy bodies these
enlightened lay people who
i know for a fact having talked to
various priests treated the legion of
mary like parliament which is probably
how they regarded them and i think we
knew that it was still very important to
the very small numbers
of above the radar traditionalists and
also was still set in aristocratic
houses but
melbourne 23 wasn't an aristocratic
house and
i say it was the embarrassment factor
the rosary seemed like
a bit of an anachronism to many
catholics
but then so certainly did adoration of
the blessed sacrament
and that has sprung back to life as a
devotional practice
and likewise a rosary so i'm not at all
surprised to hear you talking about it
with such an
enthusiasm and promoting it on twitter
but although it's been recommended to me
many times
over the last few years which you know
haven't been easy once for my family
oh god the embarrassment factor is still
there so
i mean any tips well
um you could for instance sit together
with your wonderful sister
and try that it's something lovely but
there is still the embarrassment factor
and maybe it's an english thing i mean i
don't know if you've ever seen
or saw in the pre-covered era anglicans
who are unexpectedly asked to do the
sign of peace at a service i mean they
visibly want the earth to swallow them
up and
this rosary would probably be happening
in carmel's kitchen
damien why don't you try to sitting back
to back then you don't have to look into
each other's faces while you pray
well i'll mention it to pursue she says
but just briefly
what is so special about the rosary
what's so special about the rosary um it
is an incredibly
humble thing to do it is a repetitive
thing
it is a nearly meditative thing
and you don't stand sort of face to face
with god and discuss
things out but you bow under a rhythm
and a repetition and something very
simple so
saying the five decades of a rosary
together
every child taking the lead you know for
one decade and
always you know including some special
intentions with each one
doesn't take long and but sort of lowers
you into a rhythm
that is healthy for the soul i think but
as you say it's something you learn by
doing
if you do it the first time you probably
feel very weird um if you repeatedly do
it
then it gets easier and it's part of
catholic cultures in
centuries well obviously people who
aren't catholics
probably won't feel tempted to say the
rosary
and actually it's interesting that it
was invented perhaps as early as the
fourth century by the eastern orthodox
church but they they don't say it
anymore
probably because the catholics do but i
think a lot of people would identify
with your reference to
a healthy rhythm which ties in with what
you were saying earlier about
constant digital distraction and i think
for many religious believers
especially converts faith whatever faith
is a way of
recovering a sense of rhythm of coping
with this awful
uncertainty and disorientation that
comes with
the acceleration of change social and
technological disruption
the great thing about faith is that it
can help you in difficult moments and
can carry you
and one of the things i like about
catholic twitter is
that if you have lots of twitter
followers who are catholic you will run
every morning when you check the latest
tweets
about some across somebody who asked for
prayer and then you just say a little
prayer for them it's nice
and and you know if i if i'm in a crisis
if my things are
in a bad way i can ask others to pray
for me
and that's that's nice that's comforting
well it's almost as if you've helped
create another dimension of catholic
twitter which can be incredibly toxic
i know partly thanks to me
lots of catholics really do despise each
other
thanks to the information they pick up
on twitter which is often accurate
information and the only place they're
gonna
find it out so it's morally rather
complicated at times
but then you can turn to the at edward
habsburg
twitter account and there's something
different
it's funny and pious at the same time
which is an unusual combination
wonderful combination i'm worried i'm
sounding a bit sycophantic by the way
like a
habsburg courtier but i i love it and
one of the reasons i love it is that
i know from private conversations that
you know
what's really going on why people's
passions are so inflamed
on both sides of various arguments and
that means that unlike all those
dreadful bishops who
take such pride in their contempt for
social media and everybody on it you're
able to take the poison
out of certain debates it's a bit like a
blessed emperor cal you're trying to
bring people together
and to make peace if possible and um
i'm totally aware of the catholic
twitter wars going on but i'm always
trying to you know diplomat
build bridges and be nice with everybody
well mr ambassador ashley k wood
there's a lot of stuff we could have
talked about
and perhaps will one day such as
hungary's
policies on the family and fighting the
persecution christians
for which a very effective advocate but
it's been kind of fun
letting the conversation roam so
edward thank you very much
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound amazon gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher